don't you just hate it when you're
trying to make love and then this
happens
yes episode 6 of lovecraft country has
just released with a flashback app
centered entirely in korea
in this video we'll be breaking down the
episode discussing jia's powers
atticus's role in the war and what their
relationship could mean going forward so
get ready to enlist by hitting that like
and subscribe button but before we begin
a quick disclaimer one i haven't read
the book so don't worry if you're trying
to avoid outright spoilers
and two this show deals heavily with
issues of racial injustice a subject
matter i'm continually educating myself
on so if i happen to get something wrong
please dm me or leave a message in the
comments
it's taken us 6 episodes but we finally
meet gia and my apologies if i'm getting
the pronunciation wrong
this is the woman who atticus saw as an
alien in episode 1 and who attacked him
as a hallucination in episode 2.
it's kind of fitting she appears to him
as an alien since we'll later find out
she's not human now the point of this
first scene where she dances to the 1944
judy garland film meet me in st louis is
to show us her humanity just as this
episode shows us a year in the life of
jiha
meet me in st louis shows the year in
the life of its characters
so this movie becomes her escape from
reality just like how atticus reads
books to escape his
unfortunately for gia the dancing is
merely a dream inside her head
this episode takes place in daegu south
korea around the events of the korean
war
we meet jia's mother who has pressured
her with finding a man
saying it's the only way to bring honor
back to their family
ever since the death of father they
haven't been invited to gimjang
a traditional event where families and
neighbors gather together to prepare and
preserve kimchi for the winter months
during the day gi is training to become
a nurse but all the girls here seem to
be more interested in finding a man than
on their studies she attends a speed
dating course reciting judy garland
underneath this prim exterior there are
depths of emotion
romantic longings this is a line from
the 1948 film the pirate and points at
jia's longing for love something her
mother says she can't feel because she's
not
human jia ends up bringing a man home
from the bar and as they make love
hairy tentacles emerge from her orifices
horrify
allowing her to gain all the memories of
that person's life
for example this poor victim we see him
get married have a baby and climb a
mountain that is of course before he
dies in a giant explosion of blood and
guts
as we'll find out jia is a kumiho a
spirit of a thousand-year-old fox a
creature from korean folklore that is
manifested in the form of a beautiful
woman to seduce boys and steal their
souls
years ago jia's mother made a deal with
a mudang a korean shaman
the spirit of kumiho was instilled in
jia's body to kill father a man who
molested jia as a child
while mother watched and did nothing she
was a woman with a child out of wedlock
and this man was her only way to be
rescued from
shame and disgrace it was the price she
had to pay
so now jia's mother encourages her
daughter to kill in the hopes that once
she collects a hundred souls her real
daughter will be returned to her
back at the cinema there's a brief
cartoon stating that anyone who pits one
person against another
is trying to rob you of your freedoms a
fitting cartoon since moments later
marks the start of the korean war
a war that pits two sides against one
another it's no wonder then that after
we see this cartoon we hear an american
soldier saying he's fighting for freedom
america is here to fight for your
freedom gia's mother is concerned that
she hasn't brought home anyone in a
month she just needs a few more souls
before all the memories she's absorbed
will be wiped clean that's because
gia is struggling with whether or not
she wants to change at all
her friend youngja tells her it's okay
to be different young herself is a
communist something that will get you
strung up
this pep talk would be great if it
weren't for the fact that gia isn't
human at all after one of the nurses is
found out to be a communist spy they're
taken away to be shot for many of you
this may have been a jarring scene as
it's not often we're shown
america commits such heinous war crimes
but if you want to learn more i suggest
you check out the pbs documentary kill
em all
america war crimes in korea it's here we
meet atticus who not only shoots an
innocent woman
but will later find through gs powers
engaged in acts of torture
several months later jia's only form of
escape the theater is closed with red
graffiti saying
red owned communist sympathizer she'll
break down when she finds that atticus
the man who killed her best friend
is a patient at her hospital later
vowing to kill him atticus asked her to
read the last few chapters from the
count of monte cristo his father's
favorite book we'll later learn one of
the reasons montrose loves this book is
that it's about a man who gets revenge
after facing oppression
and that alexandro dumas the novel's
author was a black man she refuses to
read it to atticus instead
spoiling the entire ending for him what
she doesn't know is that atticus has
already read it and that the ending she
gave out is that of the 1934 film of the
same name
where the two leads rekindle their
relationships whereas in the book
they don't atticus remarks i see what i
thought that change would make for a
better movie
just like the book didn't see the two
lovers end up together this same can be
said for atticus and gia
there's a great scene where jia asks
atticus and a korean-american soldier
why they fight for a country that
doesn't treat them as equals for the
korean american
other than the fact that he was drafted
he feels like he doesn't have a home
in america he gets called racist names
and in korea he's considered a pariah
atticus however
signed up willingly his joining of the
military was to get away from his
abusive and
overbearing father this was his escape
now he takes out his
violence on others jia shows up at the
military base for a night on the town
but atticus has managed to get a hold of
a projector and a judy garland movie
thanks to uncle george
they end up taking things to gia's place
where he tells her how being with her
makes him forget all the terrible things
he's done
he truly feels remorse for what he's
done and these events pain him
this is also atticus's first time and i
just hope he wraps it since she's been
with a hundred guys
she ends up telling him to leave she
originally planned to kill him but now
has developed
actual feelings and mother isn't too
pleased calling her a monster but it
begs the question
who is the real monster here she awaits
her atticus outside the base where he
tells her to leave and she opens up
about her truth
that she knew he killed her best friend
but started to develop
actual feelings for him atticus deep
down is a good man
but war tore him apart we've both done
monstrous things
but that does not make us monstrous they
make love and gia tells mother that she
will not
kill again mother was lying to her all
these years about her inability to have
feelings but now she's fallen for
atticus she tells atticus the story of
the kumiho and as they make love and she
gets lost in the ecstasy of it all
the tales come out latching onto atticus
we get a series of images in two sets
here one
is a collection of things that happened
in atticus's past
these include him with his mother
reading a comic being whipped by his dad
and torturing young ja but the second
collection seems to take place in the
future
which explains why gi knows so much
about what will happen to atticus we see
him in bed with an unknown woman now i
could be totally wrong here but i don't
think this has any significance at all
if these flashes are happening
chronologically that means this event
happened
after he got back from korea but before
he got on that bus to chicago in episode
1
meaning this was likely some one night
stand that he was using to forget the
pain of leaving gian
we then see him get on that bus to
chicago before we get a few shots of
things we haven't seen yet
one is of him getting baptized one of
letty and atticus hooked up to some sort
of contraption
all we know other than this is that gia
has seen something that will get atticus
killed
saying that if he goes home he'll die
and what was the word he translated
last episode die atticus wants to know
how jiha predicted his death just like
the translation did or at least that's
what the show is leading us to believe
we aren't sure how atticus will die
but in this universe where we know time
machines and spells that create
invulnerability exist
there are still ways he could die and
come back to life the final scene takes
place between gia
mother and the shaman as an interview
with judy garland plays in the
background
talking about how she had to put up with
years of slander
a people who didn't see her true self
it's really analogous to jia's life
experience constantly being called a
monster with only one person
seeing her true self atticus but there
are a few
interesting bits of information we get
here one we learn that atticus will not
die by jia's hands and two
atticus's visions were things she had
never encountered with any of her
previous victims
i'm curious if atticus is the first man
she's seen memories of in the future
since all her previous victims the last
memory would have been of her killing
them
that's when their life would have ended
jihan wants to know if these visions of
atticus are true
will he die and the shaman says there
will be a big price to pay for this
we don't get an answer from her only
that gia hasn't become one with the
darkness yet and that she will see
countless deaths before her journey is
done the question then becomes if
and how jia comes back into the picture
the show is really setting up a
tumultuous love triangle between atticus
letty and
jian both ledy and jia could also
potentially be
pregnant to further complicate things it
would be interesting to see if one of
those underground tunnels beneath ledis
leads to korea
remember that montrose letty and atticus
got from boston to chicago in only a
matter of minutes using it so there's
still
a lot of mystery at play here largely
surrounding what exactly gia
knows and how atticus will die
unfortunately we'll have to wait another
week
for more answers thanks for watching
everyone make sure to like the video
and subscribe and for more bad takes
come follow me on twitter and
instagram at thingstoryt until next time
remember
daddy loves you very much
you